Koby yeah what uh one patron question oh
yeah go ahead is from Henry Gonzales
from patreon hola
this is question for Steve do la what's
the bond very good
what's the fondest memory from the Kim's
of Comedy Tour I know a lot of fondest
memory I know what it I have it of the
kawaii I remember we did Kim's in San
Jose yeah and I remember when the all
the shows was completely sold out yeah
and I remember you me and Kat Ken
because the green rooms on the second
floor and you can climb out the window
to see the line yeah and I remember
seeing the line I've never seen that
line like you know dad fan is at the
club and he goes look at me I sold out
it'll go with this camera through the
audience when they're waiting in line
and I want to yell it's papered but
anyway um he's a fantastic talent should
watch his albums great guy but anyway we
were up there it go
I know I should let go yeah and we were
up there thank you so much but I
remember standing and observing the line
yeah feeling a sense of luck cuz that
was the first time I used to open up for
a bigger economy you've opened up in
football but it was the first time where
I said to myself wow this many people
and we did it I remember we were hugging
each other we did hug each other yeah on
that on that tip we're out on the
terrace yeah we're looking we're so
excited cuz just like the first time any
of us I think we're on a bill where we
saw a line around the block and yeah
that was that was pretty awesome I gotta
tell you it's like those little memories
you got to hold on to and I'm gonna say
this last thing yeah isn't that I know
you'll never do it yeah I know Ken will
never do it but if you think about it we
should try one more one more Kim's now I
was with this podcast Yeah right dude
Mike do people listen to this or
diehards yeah riot with this with your
success Ken's success right we try one
see what happens would you add one more
person
here's
and I'll make you a deal right now
Yeah right if Ken want some more money
yeah I owe it to him you can take more
vigor with that right
anyway I think you want more money you
can you can do more I would I know my
place I know my stock but there's no
denying that ken is yeah you know yeah a
phenomenal give yeah he's a big draw for
sure so if you wanted miss out knocking
you cuz I know I taking it personally do
I'm not I'm the one that brought it up I
know I would be bronze on that Olympic
platform so I know yeah for now
I came close though as gold but I'm
silver bear claw saw no but I would know
tell Ken you know can't tell Ken next
time you see him cuz I know you're
buddy-buddy with him and I am till every
time I see him I love him yeah he's the
best
I don't wanna frame pictures he has of
you guys together from Kim's a comedy
your house here big pool photo big giant
I have our first from The Wiltern
I have that frame well you do and I have
the one from Las Vegas Wow with it with
the ticket